welcome everyone uh to tonight's
discussion of the current dangers to
American democracy sponsored by the
institution for social and policy
studies um my name is Alan Gerber I'm
the Sterling professor of political
science and director of the institution
for social and policy studies and today
I'm honored to uh to share with you the
insights of our expert panel
on this important topic um one thing
about isps I just want to remind
everyone isps is a nonpartisan research
institution and um and we are uh you can
go to our website to find out more about
our mission and our our activities and
upcoming
events um there's going to be a portion
of our uh our event which is question
and answer and so I want to encourage
you to send questions for the panel at
any time so starting now uh through the
Q&A button at the bottom of your Zoom
screen and so um we're going to uh try
and cover a lot of questions so keep the
questions if you can um brief and and um
and to the point um and and so that'll
give us the opportunity to answer as
many questions as possible and I just
also want to remind everyone that
today's event is being recorded and we
hope to be able to share a link to this
event as soon as possible so now I want
to introduce tonight's panelists uh in
alphabetical order uh and briefly um
Jacob hacker is the Stanley resor
professor of political science
co-director of the Ludwig program in
public sector leadership at the L law
school and a faculty fellow at
isps um he's an expert on American
politics and policy a member of the
American American Academy of Arts and
Sciences and the American Academy of
political and social sciences and um
recently he created Apex the American
political economy exchange which is a
new program at
isps Susan Stokes is the Tiffany and
Margaret Blake distinguished service
professor at the University of
Chicago um Sue serves as director of the
Chicago Center on
Democracy uh she's a member of the
National Academy of sciences and the
American Academy of Arts and Sciences
and among her many um many important
accomplishments uh Professor Stokes is a
co-founder of brightline watch which is
a uh periodic survey of experts and the
public on the state of American
democracy and third we have Milan
um Milan is a professor of political
science at Yale and a faculty fellow at
isps who studies the politics of
authoritarian regimes democratization
support for democracy and Democratic
backsliding his book the politics of
authoritarian rule received the best
book award from the comparative
democratization section of the American
Political Science
Association so with that we now turn to
our panelists who will speak just one
after another without uh addition
Interruption by by me so with that um
Jacob please take it away great thanks
so much so it's a real pleasure to be
here and to talk about this uh somewhat
depressing subject and um there is a
reason why I have up this uh picture
from a uh 1980s um don't don't do drugs
uh commercial that uh that uh that uh
was was was uh
uh seared into my memory as I was a
child because I used I used to wake up
early and um and watch Saturday morning
cartoons and and so this announcement
come on this is your brain you've
probably seen this one before this is
your brain
uh this is your brain on drugs um you
know I was watching TV you know at 6:00
AM before my parents woke up so then I
was always wondering when somebody was
going to actually get me breakfast um
but there's a reason I'm showing this
because in a lot of ways I think that
what's happened to our democracy is can
be well summed up by thinking about how
it is that a set of polarizing and and
and um inegalitarian changes in our
political economy have changed the way
our political institutions work or or as
the case may be don't work so if you
think of the the ad for today it's you
know here's your political system uh and
this is your political system on Extreme
inequality and hyperpolarization you
take take a context a system an set of
Institutions that was set up uh in one
ERA with one set of goals and you
transport into it a very different um
set of circumstances and it creates uh
extremely different outcomes and
unfortunately uh very very uh unsettling
outcomes uh for many of us um and so the
the way I like to think about this is
that the our political institutions um
were actually very well suited to
helping the United States become a
global economic superpower in the
manufacturing era and actually lead the
transition towards a modern knowledge
economy um but that those institutions
have proved much less well suited to
dealing with the strains and
dislocations that have emerged out of
that transition um and there are two
kind of parts to this story that I'm
just going to telescope here and we can
talk about so the first part is that
these strains uh both the the shifts the
social and demographic shifts and the
economic shifts that have occurred over
the last 30 years or so have fueled a
great deal of discontent and and given
rise to what um Paul Pearson and I have
called the backlash Coalition in our
work and this Coalition is not
synonymous with but overlaps
substantially with the Contemporary
Republican party and what's important is
it includes not just um those who are uh
who have been on the kind of front lines
of the economic changes that have taken
place those who have faced dislocations
those who are concerned about the change
in character of the nation but it also
includes a significant portion of the
American economic Elite um Paul and I
called this plutocratic populism um in
our in our work and and the idea is that
although there's a sort of common
right-wing populist story here there's
actually a surprising amount of if not
direct support for this um right-wing
populism at least Tac it and uh and
indirect support for it from uh from
some of the biggest winners uh uh in the
economy today those who benefited the
most from these changes that are
creating such um backlash and the other
point that we the other thing that I
want to emphasize is that our political
institutions have not proven very
capable of dealing with this
hyperpolarization and inequality and
there's there's kind of two two um parts
to the story so first just on the
backlash Coalition um I think it's
really important to keep in mind that
there doesn't we don't have to choose
between the kind of common economic
story about how U the decline of
manufacturing uh the concentration of
prosperity in cities has has led to um
discontent and the uh equally common and
I think also very persuasive narrative
that this has a lot to do with um
concern about the shifts in America's
racial and ethnic uh makeup in the sense
of status loss that come with it I mean
these are both going on and there's a
lot of research that shows how they come
together so for example the work of
David Ur and his colleagues shows that
areas hit by big manufacturing losses
shift dramatically to the right unless
they're um unless they're relatively
diverse in which case they shift to the
left but most of the places that have
been hit have been uh have been very um
have have been much less diverse um and
the other thing I would say is that it's
pretty important to keep in mind that
our our media ecosystem and particular
The prominent role of right-wing media
it's really important in this story is
pretty distinctive um and um and has
really accentuated uh the nature of this
backlash and and the intensity of this
backlash Coalition the other thing to
say is that this backlash and this will
get me to the institutions this backlash
Coalition is concentrated in non-metro
areas which are over represented as I'll
show in our political system system now
I just mentioned that there's also a big
role for politically active wealth and I
cite a couple studies here that are very
recent that show that despite the shifts
that we've seen there still is a large
amount of support among the top
executive class among corporations for
uh the Republican Party even as to
become more right-wing populists uh and
so this poses a really acute challenge
um and and uh the the the first thing
that I just want to mention is that this
challenge is reflected in uh and and
manifested in the fact that that we've
seen the Republican Party move much more
dramatically uh to the right over the
last generation than we've seen the
Democratic party move to the left and
you can see this in if you look across
countries that that you know the
Democratic party is kind of a
conventional center-left party maybe
slightly more Center than some uh the
Republican party is really far to the
extremes and uh and I'm sure Sue and
Milan will talk about this but the other
thing I want to mention is that
the the sort of political institutions
have accentuated this
vulnerability because or accentuated
these Trends because they have
essentially overweighted those who are
most discontented with the
transformations in our in our society
and economy that are taking place so
there are two pictures here one shows
you that you know the the Senate as you
all know has this bias towards the
Republican Party the Republican party is
essentially not one a major has not
repres resented a majority of the
nation's citizens in uh the Senate um
since the 1990s um but of course it is
uh held the held the senate for a lot of
this period and is very favored to hold
the Senate again soon um and it's just
it's very it's very difficult to update
policies to deal with some of the
strains that we're facing when there is
just like very uh this system that is
very prone to gridlock when part parties
are polarized um so there's this kind of
minoritarian threat that's emerging um
that we see in particular and I think
malan will talk about this in the degree
to which there's been very aggressive
use of state level election
Administration to try to um Advantage U
the Republican party so you can see at
the state level in this picture here
that um that that you know back in the
1970s the Democrats if anything had an
edge in gerrymandering of State
Legislative districts of course that's
shifted dramatically and there States
like Wisconsin or Ohio that are just
very heavily skewed in favor of the
Republican Party despite being
relatively evenly balanced in terms of
partisan division overall and that of
course feeds into um that feeds into
National political institutions because
of course this is where districts get
drawn for National politics uh this is
where politicians are drawn from so I I
don't feel like I could do this without
at least saying a word about whether
there's uh an OP option an opportunity
to escape this um this vicious cycle and
um in our prior work Paul and I have
written about the role of business quite
a bit and and argued that if business
which once was a much more moderate
force in our politics were to do that
again that that would be really
beneficial I I have to say I don't see
that happening and I'm not sure it will
have as much effect as we once thought
it would given how far the Republican
party has moved to the right and toward
a kind of populist uh
stance uh all ultimately right I think
the the right corrective in our system
would be electoral um but and there's a
lot of talk about the fact the
Republican party is kind of exhausting
its capacity to mobilize its voters but
of course there's this real challenge U
of whether or not the um there'll be
able to be um uh uh enough of a response
given the bias of the institutions to to
see really corrective efforts as opposed
to um as opposed to further erosion of
democracy and so as I say at the end I
think that this is an area where you
really need to see mobilization broader
mobilization around electoral and
economic reform uh and political reform
um and in that as A Philip Randolph uh
famously said organization would be
critical thank
you hi everybody um thank you for coming
it's it's great to see you and um I'm
delighted to follow on on Jacob's really
interesting present I think that there's
there's quite a bit of overlap between
his um his insights and mine which I'm
gratified because he knows a hell of a
lot more about American politics than I
do um I'm gonna put some of this in a
slightly more comparative um framework
I'm a comparative politics person so
basically you know what we've seen in
the last eight years or so in um in the
US is what we call Democratic erosion or
Democratic backsliding and um that
basically means that the US like like
about two dozen other countries
democracies around the world has
experienced a decline in both horizontal
accountability which means the ability
of U co-equal branches of government to
U Monitor and influence the actions of
the um of the executive branch um and
vertical accountability by which we mean
the ability of Voters to be well
informed and to make um decisions about
uh use elections to make decisions about
who their leaders going to be um so
despite the fact that in uh in 2020 uh
Donald Trump was uh Was Defeated um
American democracy remains fragile um
and that isn't just because um seemingly
more um anti-democratic version of the
former president is is poised to become
the the GOP gop's Presidential candidate
it's also because um the the structural
causes of um of erosion have not
disappeared and it's had um enduring
effects um that also continue to you
know persist and and and probably make
further erosion that much more likely so
um
um so just to put what's happened in the
US in a somewhat more International
context the has experienced a a wave of
back of backsliding um since the late
1990s and this figure is a sort of
illustration of that so the light blue
line is the are cou um that numbers of
coups happening per year and the white
um line tracks the number of of um
eroding events um each year um so and
the instigators of the backsliding come
in two basic flavors one is right-wing
ethn nationalists um people like Trump
and Victor Orban of Hungary and and
elsewhere and the other are left-wing
populace people like um Andres Manuel
Lopez orador in Mexico or Jacob Zuma in
South Africa um so why the focusing now
on the wealthy democracies as is the
United States obviously why um have they
experienced an upsurge in right-wing
ethn nationalist parties um well you
know with a great deal of simplification
um I'm depicting the stances of major
political parties in a in a lot of um
you know this sort of describes I think
in general terms a lot of wealthy
democracies um and how they've they've
kind of arrayed themselves in the in the
past few couple decades um I'm I'm
depicting their stances on three
dimensions the um vertical Dimension is
sort of the traditional um uh large
State small state you know heavy taxes
light taxes um one
the horizontal Dimension it has to do
with economic nationalism or
globalism um and then the sort of the
front to back Dimension is about
National identities and the extent to
which those are Salient in the position
of political party and defined in kind
of exclusive or inclusive terms um in
the context of the later 20th century
de-industrialization left parties have
shifted toward more globalist and
somewhat somewhat less redistributive
stances so that's depicted here as the
sort of the difference between what I'm
calling the Legacy left and the new Left
um and in so doing they had incentives
to to to do so I won't go into why but
um but a result of this of this shift
has been that their brand as parties of
the working class became um somewhat
diluted um this the shift in a sense
opened up a space in the southwest and
front corner of this Cube occupied by
the ethn Nationalist right so think of
the mag ofaction of the Republican Party
in the US brexiteers in the UK Sweden
Democrats and many other um parties of
this ilk um not all of them have gained
power um and some of them have gained
power and not erode not that's not led
to an erosion of their democracies um
when they get access to power why does
some of erode democracies and not others
so a key risk factor and this is very
much in line with uh with what Jacob was
saying a key risk factor that we're
finding in sort of cross-national
statistical research is income
inequality um so this is a this figure
draws from a um a cross-national um
regression analysis where the dependent
variable is the probability of of of
erosion happening beginning in any given
year and the um the horizontal axis is
um Genie this the genie coefficient
which is a measure of income inequality
in this case it's post Fisk post tax
post transfer um and uh and you know
what what you're basically seeing here
is that there is a um a you know a
strong upward Trend as countries become
more unequal the the possibilities the
probabilities of erosion um become
stronger obviously there are a lot of
other factors going on and there are
other other things that that I would
mention one of them being a kind of
contagion or demonstration effect that
we also see and I think it helps to
account for the the kind of the wave
function that we saw earlier um but what
you see here you know at the highest
level of income inequality countries
like South Africa and Botswana um the
the probability of erosion Rises to
around 30% um in countries that are very
equal so you know think the Scandinavian
countries Sweden other um northern
European countries um the the the the
probability drops to the low single
digits um our calculation for the US was
about in in 2017 was about 9% um which
isn't a very big number but it's a
terrifyingly big number um as an annual
probability of the beginning of an
erosion event um and it's also kind of
an order of magnitude larger than the
the calculations of the probability of
democratic instability when Scholars um
kind of plugged the US characteristics
in the that period into um uh old models
that came from from that were designed
to explain um uh military coups okay I'm
sorry could you could you define a a
democratic erosion event just to kind of
give folks a sense of what you're what
you're talking about some concrete
examples of what you mean yeah so um
actually our measure of this is heavily
depends on work by melis leens who was a
graduate student in her dissertation
that she wrote at Yale a few years ago
um and what so so what she stresses is
this I mentioned at the outset the a
kind of decline in both horizontal and
vertical accountability so um and
concretely we measur this with data from
um varieties of democracy which is a
Swedish um organization that collects
data on all kinds of things related to
democracy and other kinds of governments
so basically if you already are a
democracy meaning that you've had a
peaceful transition of power sometime
the last five years and you experience a
certain a large enough decline in in
measures of horizontal and vertical
accountability you get counted as a as a
um a uh a an ero that that would be the
beginning of a of a a kind of erosion a
period of erosion um so this includes
countries you know kind of familiar set
of countries like um Hungary under Orban
as I mentioned Poland until recent the
the Polish um under the the peace
governments um the US under Trump um The
Mex Mexico under the the current um
government um Bolivia these are now
talking more about cases of as I
mentioned before sort of leftwing
populist erosion I'm happy to answer
more questions about that if that would
be helpful okay um so I alluded earlier
to three wealthy
democracies um all of um all have
nurtured right ethn nationalist parties
um only the United States it by the
method that I just described counts in
most people's in in our calculations and
in most people's books as a case among
these three of democratic erosion
beginning in
2017 um the UK was kind of a close call
and it is a country where income
inequality has risen a lot in the last
Decades of since the last Decades of the
20th century and um approaches the level
of the US and it was kind of a close
call um and I can talk more about why so
there were elements of democratic
erosion but not to the degree that we
that we saw in the United States and
then Sweden is another country where
there's a very powerful um and very
electorally successful right-wing ethn
nationalist party which is now sort of
implicitly part of a governing Coalition
um but there is there's no Democratic
erosion in in Sweden there's no
challenge to the Integrity of the
Judiciary there's no questioning of
Elections as mechanisms of um of um of
uh vertical account ability um the Press
doesn't get beaten up and so on and so
forth um okay so why does inequality
encourage erosion I'm probably running
low on time let me just say very briefly
that one reason and this is something
that that Milan can talk a lot more
about is that um po countries that are
polarized by income also tend to have
more polarized politics and for reasons
that Milan and his Co colleagues have
explained very well polarization tends
to encourage Democratic erosion because
uh vot voters are more willing to sort
of say yeah I don't really like the fact
that this guy is beating up on on the
press or undermining uh judicial
Independence but God forbid that the
opposition come to power um so that's
one reason and um you can see here that
these countries sort of line up um in
terms of the level of polarization again
this is coming from um VM data a second
reason has to do with what we're calling
um uh so the effect of income inequality
on um a kind of cynicism or skepticism
about the ability of political
institutions to make any real difference
in people's lives um and this is kind of
a mood that again is kind of encouraged
by um by backsliding leaders um and
leads to what we're calling
institutional nihilism um and you can
see that we're finding that in uh you
know sort of measures of institutional
nihilism agreement to survey questions
like do you agree that we can cannot fix
the problems in our political
institutions we need to tear them down
and start over and when you expose
people to you remind people about how
unequal um their country is the us and
we did this in Mexico as well you tend
to get higher levels of agreement with
that with those kinds of responses um so
just to finish up if uh you know this is
if if we wanna if we want to have Heroes
who are going to go out and fight
against Democratic erosion um we've got
our current president who's made a
priority of of uh of trump to convince
people that democracy is really worth it
um but the other guy here is um Sean
feain who is um the leader of the the
UAW and he and other labor leaders have
um have you know led us into a period of
some relative successes of um in strikes
and in the ability of unions to um to
begin to chip away at this you know kind
of extreme income inequality that um
that our country has experienced and
that contributes to to um the erosion of
democratic institutions here so so with
that I will
close it's uh it's an honor to continue
here and join Sue and Jacob uh in uh
offering my perspective on how to
diagnose uh what might be the dangers to
the US democracy I would like to do so
by introducing a few elements of a study
that I did joint me with mad Graham who
is uh our former graduate and currently
an assistant professor at Temple
University um we were trying to figure
out to what extent Americans are willing
to prioritize Democratic principles uh
over partisan ends and crucially also to
figure out what do they believe about
others commitment to democratic
principles and whether those beliefs are
warranted in facts and here I'm showing
you a slide uh that summarizes one
scenario that repr presented a
representative sample of Americans with
and we were trying to figure out we
trying to find a way to gauge their
commitment to democracy based on this
scenario so the scenario for instance
summarizes um a situation a real world
situation that that happened in Missouri
so this was a study that we conducted
both in 2020 and 2022 and this is a
scenario from 2020 where the Missouri
legislature was considering changing how
it does redistricting and there were two
groups advocating for different ways of
doing it the status quo was there's a
non that there's a nonpartisan
demographer but there was also another
group called Fair Missouri that was
advocating for the return of the ability
to direct redistricting to the state
legislature which was controlled by
Republicans so in effect partisan
redistricting by
Republicans so this is a real world
scenario and we asked respondents to
decide how they would allocate 10 cents
between these two groups what are
interested is to what extent people are
willing to allocate the money to the
group that Advocates the more democratic
the less partisan what we call the
principled option this is in this
scenario that's clean Missouri that
advocated for nonpartisan redistricting
as opposed to one that may Advance their
partisan interests in this case if
you're a republican you face a tradeoff
between an option that would allow you
to further your partisan interests but
crucially at the expense of democracy um
and
so let me show you what happened
depending on whether you were faced with
such a partisan trade-off or such a
trade-off between partisan princip uh
partisanship and Democratic principles
and the first uh maybe illustrate what's
going on is I'll show you what the
Democrats did in this scenario in this
scenario the Democrats both partisan and
Democratic interests are clear here that
is they don't want Republicans to be
able to gerrymander and so they should
donate most of their money to clean
Missouri which is advocating for
nonpartisan redistricting and that is
indeed what
happened slide here shows the amount
donated on the horizontal axis to what
we call the principled option um that is
the option that was more consistent with
Democratic Fairplay as you can see
Democrats when faced between these two
choices uh in the state of Missouri were
overwhelmingly donating most of their
endowment to the option to the
principled option to the group that
advocated for non-partisan redistricting
rather than uh one done by a partisan uh
in this case Republican controlled
legislature uh it reveals I think two
things first of all the Democrats in
this scenario knew very well where
either Democratic principles or their
part partisan interests lie they donated
most of their money to the principled
option but now look what what happens
when we asked Republicans to donate 10
cents and how they would donate it
remember this is the group that here
faces a tension between their partisan
interests and Democratic principles you
see that a majority of Republicans in
fact decided to donate less to the
partisan uh to the principal option to
clean Missouri and more to the group to
the partisan option to the group that
advocating returning redistricting
powers to the Republican control legis
the median donation was only three cents
out of 10 to the principled option and
the mean donation was about 4 cents in
other words uh the average individual
donated a majority of her endowment to
the partis rather than the principled
option and only 29% of subjects of
Republicans in this case uh donated to
the option that's consistent more
consistent with Democratic principles
and this effect highlights uh how I view
uh the main threats uh uh to to US
democracy uh at one level it is the fact
that this is even possible that voters
in the State uh get to choose how
redistricting is done and I think in the
comparative context the United States is
unique in the sense that state level
institutions
legislatures um sometimes in conjunction
with the governor have the ability and
as a result the opportunity to shape the
fundamentals of political competition
including how redistricting is done who
can vote and so on this is this is very
unique uh around the world and it simply
creates an Institutional opportunity uh
to rig the game in one's favor the other
condition that I would like to highlight
is in effect the shape of this histogram
that is that the vast majority of the
type of voter that in this scenario
faced the tradeoff between her partisan
interests and Democratic principles
decided to side with partisan interests
and that is what we find throughout the
study both about Democrats and
Republicans and I see that as the other
main structural uh condition that
represents a threat to democracy and
that is that most people when facing a
conflict between partisanship and
Democratic principles are willing to
side with the former thank you
great um thanks very much panelists uh
so um I guess if uh if um the panelist I
guess we should join as a panel um now
and I just just I have a couple quick
questions to kick things off and then we
can turn to questions um from the
audience so I just want to just ask Sue
just a clarification question regarding
um income inequality do you find that um
the in income inequality relationship
between between income inequality and
Democratic erosion does that hold for
high income countries as well as
lowincome countries so
so right right let me that's the
question uh so so if you interact in
so I let this one answer I don't think
it's the answer the question you're
asking but we also look at GDP per
capita separately you know as as another
factor and and question about
interaction yeah right we had I I don't
remember um so my co-author on that
paper is another recent Yale grad named
Eli raal Yale is full of amazing
graduate students who um and uh I don't
remember I'm gonna I'm gonna find out
but income itself has a sort of unstable
suggestive but unstable effect the the
you know the the G the genie effect is
just like we couldn't get rid of it no
matter what we did you know it was sort
of however you measure it however you
measure the the dependent variable you
know it's it's you know the only way we
got rid of it was unplugging our
computers so it was pretty pretty
remarkable you can kick the you tried
kicking the computer
yeah okay so and then then my my second
question and this is really for all the
panels panelists is just um uh this is
obviously the idea of democratic erosion
in the United States is a very
frightening Prospect um and at one level
it's obviously I'll just say with it's
very frightening on the other level it
you know you wonder whether or not this
is a bunch of political scientists
engaging and
catastrophizing um and whether this is a
real uh a real thing or not and so um
could you I I mean each of you or any of
you could you spell out what you think
of as
Pathways um that you think are plausible
um uh maybe one or two scenarios that
you can think of that would uh that
would produce what you've defined as
Democratic erosion us I I'm using Sue's
term but Democratic backsliding I think
that's what Milan um was was referring
to it as um and then you know just a
little bit about the plausibility in
your view of those of those scenarios um
anyone can start is yeah sure I can jump
in real quick um so I I share that um
that General orientation that often
there's I fear that you know that we who
are focused so much on politics can get
ourselves much more upset um than those
who are casual observers but I think in
this case um if anything I feel like um
we're under ating some of the risks and
I I would say there are two two Pathways
so the first thing to say is I think
this is very consistent with what Sue
was saying is that your concern is is
erosion not um collapse right um that
the way democracies tend to end you know
in a whimper not a bang in the
Contemporary era as as as zot and um and
litzky have shown in their book um and
so what you're really worried about is
this sort of self-reinforcing process um
and I think I think both of us are
arguing that inequality polarization and
the distinctive character of American
institutions I say all three of us are
but certainly Sue and I were emphasizing
this have created a kind of more what I
call a vicious cycle right where there
is real possibility of self-reinforcing
erosion of democratic institutions um
and um and I I don't discount the
possibility that there would be a a more
like gr dramatic um single event and we
you know there's a lot of concern and I
share that concern about um you
authoritarian minded president um bent
on uh revenge against political enemies
and much more Savvy about how to use the
institutions of American government
could well get a lot farther than um
said president did while in office but
um but I want to highlight that I think
the trends that we've seen that are
really linked to this other form of of
democratic erosion too namely the sort
of creeping minoritarian ISM um that
Milan talked about in that the
supporting of policies that that um and
institutions uh and institutional
changes that sort of chip away at the
the Hallmarks of democracy and um and
that I think because it builds on some
of the the features of our political
institutions that can be exploited for
partisan gain is is in some ways kind of
more Insidious and difficult to counter
um form of erosion and so you
know we I don't know if I if people a
generation ago would have expected the
level of of really extreme partisan
Jerry mandering that's been that's
taking place and been sanctioned by the
court um certainly there was before the
Contemporary Urban rural split occurred
there wasn't nearly as much of a bias in
the institutions that are based on um
that are Mal portioned in favor of of of
less
Urban places um as we have today um or
you know the kinds of challenges that
have taken place at the state level to
election results all those seem to me to
be pretty fundamental shifts and then if
we Step Beyond kind of Institutions I
mentioned and I really want to emphasize
like the kind of claims against
democracy that are becoming and against
um partisan opponents that are being
used in um extreme media particularly on
the right but on both the right and the
left I think it's also a really
significant ero of core aspects of our
Democratic um Heritage so that to me
is that's a long answer to a short
question but I think it's I think I
don't want to say we should all be
freaked out it's not like in that scene
in airplane if you remember that that
80s funny movie where like there was a
sign that said don't panic when the
plane started going down and then at one
point it just shift to panic and
everyone jumped up and started screaming
I'm not saying panic but I'm saying be
concerned um and be be uh focused on on
what are the real sources of this of
this erosion good thank you Jacob um Sue
do you have any what what are some of
the scenarios that in the US context you
are are are you think of as worrisome um
and then um Milan is now back so one of
the things that I worry about in the US
context is the um unshake ability of um
of Donald Trump's electoral base um and
it's sort of seeming kind of insularity
from any kind of you know negative
information or negative negative facts
about about the candidate about the
party about the policies um when you
look at other countries that have um had
periods of erosion and and kind of and
kind of set them aside one of the things
that you see is that you know parties
lose elections and um eroding parties
lose elections and they really kind of
it's it's possible to undo some of what
what happened um or and and you know and
you don't have the same sometimes you
have challenging of the of the the
election so um xer bolsonaro in Brazil
was very much like Trump in that he
claimed before the election that there
was going to be massive fraud but he
didn't really double down on that claim
afterwards so much and that's probably
because he was really worried about
prosecution and he is being prosecuted
so um but you know the the the UK is an
interesting is an interesting experience
because they really did have a very
close call maybe closer call than we
realized in in the US so the proration
crisis where um prime minister um
Johnson um closed down the um the the
parliament um which is not something
that that never happens but it was found
that he had done that in a unlawful
manner um I'm not sure what unlawful and
illegal are the difference between them
but that's what the court decided in in
the UK and so that's that's kind of a
big thing and then they also have um
engaged in restri you know restrictions
of ballot to ballot access like the US
actually you know like the US a country
in which there's very little electoral
fraud in fact the elections are are are
much more heavily um regulated there um
and the right to protest has been um
curtailed in ways that have been that
have been um lasting in fact we saw a
lot of drama around that the last few
days um but what what happened to to
Johnson was that he was dumped by his
political party and he was dumped by his
political party and granted it's a you
know parliamentary system it's easy iier
for the party to to get rid of its prime
minister you don't need a new election
you don't even need a party election
there um but the reason he was dumped
was that he was very unpopular or to put
it the other way around had he had the
persistent kind of level of popularity
that that Donald Trump has in the US
they might well have hung on to him and
then we might have seen more more of an
unraveling um in the UK so that that's a
real source of concern for
me great thank you um Milan do you have
anything you wanted to add
I apologize I I Disappeared for a minute
there and was your question about what
are the yeah the question is um are
there any scenarios that you might that
that you know that just basically are
there any scenarios that you are
especially worried about you mentioned
state level um uh mations in your
presentation is that what you're
concerned about um Mo mostly or what are
the things you're concerned about in
terms of scenarios for Democratic
backsliding so those state level
um you know
disenfranchisement um Jerry mandering
that that was happening before um the
Trump presidency it's happening now and
those are the the the institutional
opportunities that are unique to the
United States and that are being taken
advantage of uh by both parties and I
think that's very concerning and maybe
let me add two other elements that I
think are structurally different um
let's say from what was happening four
years ago or six years ago and the first
one is I think that uh similar to what
Sue mentioned that Post January 6
Republicans are different and maybe one
way I would describe this in concrete
terms that we see it in the study that I
briefly previewed uh as I mentioned we
conducted two studies one in 2020 just
before the 2020 election and the another
one in the 2022 election and what we saw
uh in the study conducted just prior to
the midterms that is after January 6
2020 one is that we saw that
Republicans um are unwilling to punish
so whereas in 2020 they were but in 2022
they were unwilling to punish one type
of undemocratic behavior and that is uh
denying the outcome of Elections
questioning the fairness or or the
conduct of Elections when their
candidate was claiming and these were
real world candidates that were simply
questioning the results of the 2020
presidential elections or some other
elections Republican voters were willing
to go along with it in some cases that
carried a premium and so that's very
different from the kind of partisan
asymmetry that we have observed before
where actually voters on both sides were
willing to overlook Democratic defects
on their own
side this is very different now and
maybe the last comment um I would have
is that another feature that is
different from just a Fe few years ago
is that both sides are increasingly
willing to justify their own
undemocratic behavior by pointing to the
other side's on Democratic Behavior so
to to maybe give one concrete example uh
the Democrats um when they redistricted
the state of New York um just before the
2022 uh 20 22 midterms that
redistricting was ruled as
unconstitutional in New York because it
was gerrymander but the rationale that
was given is that we have to do this
because Republicans are doing this
elsewhere and if we are not doing if we
don't do this we will be hurting
ourselves politically and and if you if
you look at the some of the commentary
on this and Reporting what was
interesting that is the journalists
sometimes noted and you know and no
voter is going to punish their own party
for Jerry mandering so there's no
political cause to this and I think this
kind of tit fortat where one one side is
saying we have to play dirty because the
other side is already doing it uh can
kind of spiral out of
control okay well that is a a really a
great way to transition to the questions
because I find that really upsetting and
disturbing I I I mean this the the idea
that sort of Norm violation leads to a
kind of spiral of escalation of you know
of Norm violation that that that is I
would just say I I'm sorry maybe I
should stop here but I would say the the
scenarios that seem most disturbing to
me for extreme problems have that
feature to them where people start down
on a set of things each they start down
on a down a path which through a series
of I have to do this because they did
this or if I don't do it they'll do it
um that logic can lead you very far uh
down the road in a scary Direction and
um anyway on on that note why don't we
turn to our um our audience um I'm GNA
Rick uh Harrison um has uh synthesized
some of the questions um and so I'm
going to read some of them um to you and
I I'm I'm and let me just go ahead and
and anyone who wants I don't think any
of these at least the first Bunch are
not directed to any particular panelist
so whoever thinks uh they have something
insightful to say should please share
that with our our audience
um okay question here's a question uh
Peter churchin has written that we are
in for a period of ongoing instability
because of four underlying societal
forces popular IM miseration leading to
mass mobilization potential Elite over
production um which I that's his famous
hypothesis about Elite over production
um failing fiscal health and weaken
legitimacy of the state and geopolitical
factors and so some of those things were
mentioned by I guess Jacob mentioned and
as well Susan and also I guess Milan as
well um what do you think about the
implications of this thesis um what do
you feel about the thesis do you is this
do you find this useful this to lead
over produ especially lead over
production and legitimacy uh problems do
you find that a useful framework and how
does that help you think about these
questions
I'm very interested in hearing what you
think about Elite over production I but
any of the anything in this question I'd
be interested in hearing your reaction
to are you familiar with this Elite over
production thesis okay it's it's we
don't have enough time to go into it but
basically there a lot basically you have
if I if I've got it right when you have
when you produce more political Elites
than you have places for them in society
that's the Tinder for um political
conflict and potential major changes in
the political system that that and that
this I think goes back to um is it
paredo who talked about elite elite
fractures being the foundation for um
for political change uh as opposed to
mass-based political change obviously
you know what a great comparative
politics scholar I am so um any any com
any comments from our colleagues on
that I'm I'm tempted to say we're going
to edit this part out of the of the
video okay um next
question uh so any comments please yeah
I don't know if I have anything to say
on Elite over production but um but I
will say that the the role I think both
Sue and I were emphasizing the degree to
which the concentration of economic
rewards is quite consequential that's
one kind of elite um actually I think
probably there's a one of the big
problems in our politics today is is
linked to what you were saying about
Norm erosion is the people who go into
office increasingly have to be partisan
Warriors right and so they're you know I
think we really can't understate the
role of Elites in this process so is in
shap in both shaping how non- Elites are
thinking but also in uh their own intern
their own struggles and so one thing
that I think is quite clear is that the
pool of people who are going into into
public office now is very much shaped by
this both this
very bifurcated medal ecosystem that I
alluded to and by the sense that there's
a struggle that existential struggle
that each party is engaged in and I do
think there are differences between the
parties in this regard and I've been
studying the Democratic party a lot
lately because I I I was studying the
Republican party for so much of my
career and I do think one thing that is
different is that the the Democratic
party still has a lot of people who for
one of a better way of putting it kind
of want to do policy um and that has a
kind of
cohesive it induces a kind of cohesion
across the party if you look at the
Republican say in the house one of their
big problems right is that they they
they lack this kind of common
denominator of well we just wanted like
do do policy things through government
right um there's there's sort of one
faction that's trying to um that's
trying to um to to win favor on
conservative social media there's other
factions that would like to do policy
things there's others that would think
the Supreme Court's really all that
matters there's you know and so the it I
think creates a much more fractured
party and I think fracture is kind of
bad like I think that in general you
want parties that can behave a bit more
cohesively um and will discipline of
course their members when they um when
they're behaving ways that sort of
reflect poorly on the party overall and
so not to to paint the Democrats as um
as being um really high performers in
this regard but I do think one thing
that we should be thinking about is like
what you know how does the Republican
party because we can't have our system
does not work without two parties that
are relatively well functioning how do
we get the Republican party to function
as a more cohesive party um and not just
in a way the way that Milan suggests
they might function as a party so I'm
sorry that that was exactly on Elite
over production but I actually think
it's really important to think about the
the Elites in American politics and how
they play into this um this this process
okay Sue mil Milan do you want have
anything you want to say or like we
should move on to next
question sure next question sounds great
okay next question um uh do you think um
that the candidate selection mechanism
so we've got the situation in the United
States where we have Donald Trump and
Joe Biden likely to be the next
Presidential candidates um that's a
function to a great extent of the
political institutions for selecting
office holders is there anything in your
research that suggests that there are
better and worse ways uh in terms of the
political
institutions uh for um uh uh that might
help us to avoid Democratic erosion so
just to amplify on this a little bit you
you suggested these deep structural
economic factors attitudinal factors are
there any institutional factors that
might be helpful um I mean Milan of
course discussed the um state level um
institutional Authority but Sue any of
your comparative politics work that
might give us ideas about better and
worse um political institutions or or
milin anything that you would
suggest um so you know I think that
there there are it's commonly viewed
that there aspects of the way that we um
select candidates and and elect um
office holders in the US that that
contribute to polarization and and um
and to party and discipline that that
Jacob was just discussing so um and and
there are some kind of structural
aspects of that that so the United
States has gone through sometimes called
the Great sort where we have an
increasing kind of homogenization
regionally um and a electoral District
um of uh so Less heterogeneity in terms
of political references and and and
other factors so that tends to produce
um uh Representatives who are not um
vulnerable to being um losing elections
or to the the other party but rather the
the dynamic tends to be within their own
party and that that can contribute to um
to the kind of polarization that that uh
that Milan was talking about there
actually has been I mean there are
trade-offs involved in all of these
kinds of institutional factors so in
Latin America where I uh I have more
Regional expertise there actually has
been a a shift toward um party primaries
not so much for um members of the
legislature who tend to be elected in
proportional representation on party
lists but for um for executives for for
presidents and uh the reason parties
like to do that is that it it opens the
process and potentially chooses more
popular um candidates who will do better
in the general election and also I think
gives voters a sense of ownership having
participated in a in an Open Primary and
decided Well I'm going to vote it for
the in the P Primary in Mexico I'm more
likely than to go on and vote for the
pon um candidate in the election so
they're they're trade-offs um uh and um
but there certainly are some um some
particular features of of American
institutions which Jacob was was talking
about as well as Milan that that tend to
enhance um increase polarization I'm
just going to add one other thing this
is kind of adding to the mix the super
interesting um conversation about
polarization there's there's so so one
of the drawbacks of Po of polarization
as a strategy of democratic eroders is
that it mobilizes your base but it also
mobilizes the other guys so you know
Donald Trump says the Democrats are an
angry mob who don't want to who want to
open the border and so on so and that
you know that gets his folks revved up
but it also tends to get Democrats
revved up so um there's another strategy
that we have been detecting in our
research another kind of rhetorical
strategy um that we call trash talking
democracy Milan has heard about this um
where the it's it's not so much you
don't badmouth the other party you
badmouth the institutions um so you know
the courts um are full of corrupt um
actors the Press is
incompetent um the uh you know the the
legislature the opposition in the legisl
are are you know the legislature is um
is you know unworkable and so um the the
impact of of that is to we find just as
an empirical matter to um kind of um
Tamp down any kind of enthusiasm or
optimism about the about institutions
working and that's also something that I
think is very is sort of exaggerated in
the American context because we do this
this goes back to what Jacob was saying
we do have a whole you know big chunk of
one of our major political parties who
are people who really don't believe in
government and don't believe in public
policy and um and sort of make the the
the failure to Pro to provide good
Services a kind of self-fulfilling
function there's a wonderful book by a
an American sociologist Arley Russell
hawsh Hawk Shield about um why is it the
people in cancer alley in Louisiana um
who understand perfectly well that
they're being poisoned by the U
petrochemical industry why did they
support tea party anti- um
environmentalist um lawmakers and one of
the reasons is that they see that the
the even at the state level that you
know the the the kind of EPA equivalent
in the state of Louisiana does a
terrible job they can't they don't get
anything done they don't actually
protect them um of course that's a
result of De of defunding and and and uh
and you know a a kind of starving of the
institution but then that then that
becomes evidence that there's no point
in um in electing you know
environmentalists representatives are
trying to push agencies to do a better
job because um you have before you you
know evidence that these that these
institutions don't
work thanks Sue um um Milan do you have
any comments maybe maybe maybe just some
comments on this institutional question
so I I don't see much of a you I don't
see a clear evidence favoring or not
favoring a system with P party primaries
over system over a system without Prim
party primaries but but what strikes me
as being directly relevant to democratic
erosion is the fact that the very tight
two-party system that exists in the
United States creates a very Stark
choice for voters right so if you have
if one party is proposing a candidate
that is has authoritarian Tendencies but
at the same time represents in a
meaningful sense also the policy
preferences of Voters then a supporter
of those policy preferences faces a
tough choice they might vote for a
candidate who is democratic but on the
other side politically as in advocating
for policies that they disagree with or
they must put up with a candidate who is
um you know violating Democratic Norms
but also happens to advocate for the
kind of policies that they that they
like and this is a very Stark binary
Choice that's in effect a product of the
two-party system and that in most places
which have multiple parties does not
have to be as Stark because in addition
let's say to a conservative who is
authoritarian there will be also a party
that also have has conservative leanings
but is perfectly compliant with
Democratic principles and so in some
some sense voters democracy has a very
high price in the United States for a
subset of Voters who face these kind of
trade-offs and so in terms of
institutional Solutions I'm kind of very
much interested in what's going to come
up with
um come out of the ranked uh ranked
Choice experiments which still in the US
function in the context of of the two
major parties but because they do not
have a stark duvergerian pressures they
do not face voters who may have somewhat
eclectic combination of preferences they
may not be aligned exactly uh the way
the two major parties are they may be
sincerely voting for their first
preference without having to sacrifice
uh their vote
great thank you I mean I guess another
issue related to what you were saying
Milan is that when you have two parties
if you trash the other party it's a
sumzero uh game whereas if they're
multiple parties trashing the other
party may or may not re down to your
benefit to the same extent I think there
would be the interaction effect between
Sue comments and and my comments
excellent thank you wonderful um next
question
uh to what extent if any might the
effects of
disinformation apart from the effects of
objective conditions such as inequality
affect your analysis so I guess the
general question is to what extent is
the erosion of
democracy um uh affected by the
information environment that that you
know we're now
experiencing I I mean I should say I've
mentioned rightwing media and media in
general a number of times so I'll just
emphasize that again and say that one
way that inequality has factored in or
at least this was what um Paul and I
argued in our book let the me tweets is
that it um that inequality by
um uh uh creating essentially tensions
for both parties coalitions but
particularly for the Republican
Coalition with its long-standing ties to
business but its increasing Reliance on
working class white votes for that party
to try to shift the the scope the the
focus of conflict from kind of First
Dimension material size of government
issues towards more uh what sometimes
called second Dimensions issues around
race cultural conflict and I I I just
want to be clear there's a lot of second
dimension appeals made by democrats as
well but I think it's really important
to see how that strategy right has play
has been both um so that's not a direct
effect of inequality if you will it's an
effective inequality is mediated by
political strategies competition between
the parties John RoR uh my our colleague
um now retired made argument along these
lines many years ago which is basically
if you introduce these second dimensions
of conflict then you're going to get
these cross-class parties they're going
to be cleaved much more around cultural
and social issues and with the
Republican party in particular there's
just no question that that strategy
right which took the objective change
but then translated into a certain kind
of response was very has been greatly
furthered by the rise of a distinctive
right-wing media ecosystem and so um it
starts as talk radio it runs uh up uh
into and through Fox News which now is a
moderate player in some of the rightwing
media circles um there's been a ton of
research on this that shows that there
is a lot of disinformation and
misinformation in uh this more isolated
ecosystem perhaps the most persuasive
argument that I seen about this because
of course these can come like become
like essentialist arguments like somehow
the rightwing is going to be is more
prone to dishonesty but actually the
best argument I've seen is just the
nature of the ecosystems themselves so
if the left of center ecosystem is kind
of broad one that includes a lot of
mainstream media right it's just much
more likely to police um very um uh uh
inaccurate and extreme stuff right
rightwing Meto system is a more
self-contained unit that's true both in
terms of how these these media nodes
kind of interact with each other as Yi
wler has shown in his work but it's also
true in who actually consumes the media
right so if you're someone who dabbles a
little bit in this range of media which
is true of a lot of people in the center
right then you're going to get exposed
to a bunch of stuff if you look at the
people particularly the most strong
supporters of kind of we've sometimes
talked to them about them today as magga
C you know Maga make America great again
candidates those folks are much more
likely to congregate among the most
conservative media sources where they're
not necessarily getting exposed to some
of that contrary information so again I
I just think it's um really important
that we understand that that that our
institutions are distinctive and also if
you look across countries there are very
few countries I think Israel is really
the major example that you see in the
cross National research where there's so
much distrust particularly among
conservatives of mainstream media
sources and where there's so much
Reliance on uh a kind of distinctive
brand of media by
partisans great um Milan and Sue do you
have anything to add about the um
communication
environment I can't tell if Milan are
you are you looking to get rid of your
mute or are
you I'm I apologize no I don't think I
have anything to say okay um Sue do you
have anything you want to add
no I I agree with terrific um okay
question um thank you all for your
informative talks okay I agree with that
go okay what are some actions that can
be done or are already being done to
counteract the erosion of
democracy so um actually Sue could you
also say just a word about what um what
a a bright line watch is because I I
think I think people might who are
interested in this topic might be
interested in learning more about that
as well as answer because I think it's
relevant to the question of you know
what can you do about the erosion of
democracy as an a public that's more
alert to the the the fact that there are
threats to our democracy is probably
part of the answer to that
question so um there
you know uh I think participation is
super important so thinking about what
we can do as individuals who may be you
know students or professors or people
you know working in um in non um you
know non official kinds of jobs um I
participation is very important um if
you know Milan is completely right that
we have um all kinds of biases and
tendencies to turn turn a blind eye to
undemocratic behaviors by our own
parties but um to the extent that um it
becomes really crucial and I think we
are really at a at a Crossroads in in
our at our in our country right now um
to sort of you know recommit to
democracy as a as a kind of system of
government and and set of principles and
make that a kind of central point to
your own participation and the way you
talk to other people about politics ICS
um separate from the kinds of public
policy issues that we all care a lot
about many of us care very passionately
about public policy issues um but
separate from from those kinds of
concerns um I think that there is a real
need to sort of redouble think hard and
talk hard you know talk with people
about what is it the Democracy does and
what what what does it look like it
doesn't do very well and um you know I
talked a moment ago about the the this
kind of phenomenon of of den of of um
eroding backsliding leaders um having a
a strategy of denigrating democracy not
so much democracy r large they usually
say it's a good system of government but
these particular institutions really
really are Hollow and and corrupt and
and not worth it so don't worry about it
when I attack them so um you
know I I think there's a dialogue to
have with many different kinds of people
I personally feel a strong need to have
a a dialogue with the left on this um
and with young people and I start in my
own household where I have um you know
teenagers who are skeptical for sure and
who um are quick to pick up on the
failures of democracy even when it works
pretty well um so we have all kinds of
you know so the way to to defend
democracy is not to whitewash it it's
not to say um it's a it it has worked
very well for um for um in the history
of the United States it has had all
kinds of biases and um has
institutionalized many elements of
racism and sexism and all kinds of
things that we want to overcome um
nevertheless um if you study the
experiences of other countries where
people lose the ability to kick their
the government out of office by voting
them out that is not a good place to be
it's a place to be where civil rights
are not respected where the rights to
protest are not respected where freedom
of speech is not respected so um I I
think that a kind of um thinking hard
about the difference between a sharp
critical constructive eye toward our own
political institutions as opposed to you
know the kind of institutional nihilism
that um that many political leaders are
only too happy to encourage us to
embrace that that's an important
starting
point and could you just say a quick
word about um project watch yeah so um
in uh late 20 uh when was it I guess it
was coming up to the election in 2016 um
the a lot of economists got very upset
because um candidate Trump was Raising
questions about the the veracity and
reliability of um official government
statistics on things like unemployment
rate um and they um wrote a public
letter that was signed by many former
you know Nobel laurates and former um
presidents of the American economics
Association and so forth that said hey
you know the where would we be without
the um the Bureau of Labor Statistics
where would we be without these
institutions it's not a good thing to to
to um to question these very important
institutions and and question sort of
the the scientific basis of um of of of
economic of Economics um and um I
remember I was having a conversation
with our colleague um gretan helmy at
the University of Rochester and sort of
very smugly saying oh these economists
they they sure wait till the last minute
to do this and then it was then she sort
of said hey have we done anything like
this so we circulated a letter of great
concern about um you know the threat
that that um you know certain parts of
the discourse and sort of you know
attacks on the Press um that point
verbal attacks on the Press attacks on
uh you know very virulent attacks on
political opponents on um on immigrants
and so forth um that that seemed to
represent a um a a you know a threat to
Potential Threat to to democratic
institutions in the United States and
that elicited a very very strong
response we had I think every almost
every living um past president of the
American of the uh the American
Political Science Association and just
scores of our colleagues signed the
letter and we um after the election we
thought okay we should do something and
the first thing we decided to do um was
to put together an email list of our
colleagues around the country and um get
them to tell what they think matters for
democracy so we have those of you who
filled out these long surveys know there
are about 27 different dimensions that
we talk about what is democracy and then
that same set of of um Dimensions you
know how are we doing how's the US doing
on these things and we've branched out
and done other kinds of um other kinds
of questions and other kinds of studies
but that's the the basic so it's a it's
a collaboration between Dartmouth um
University of Rochester and was Yale now
University of
Chicago great thank you very much Sue um
uh again the question um what are some
actions that can be done or are already
being done to counteract the erosion of
democracy um Milan is there something
you'd like to to add to
that maybe briefly to to uh characterize
what I think is the main force that is
you know that that acts in you know to
to defend the democracy and I think that
main Force are the voters I think as
voters as being the ultimate check on
any possible politician that undermines
democracy and I think when we think
about what kind of Voters that are um
the kind of study that I highlighted
earlier um I've tried to do several of
those around the world and basically try
to look at what are the kind of
characteristic of the kind of voter that
when the kind of party or candidate that
they would normally vote for says
something undemocratic or proposes
something undemocratic that that voter
is willing to say I'm not voting for you
just because of that right and I think
there are there are two actionable
predictors of that kind of voter or
correlates of that kind of voter and the
first type is well that kind of voter
tends to be a Centrist or moderate right
so they are not they are not Hardline
partisans because those are unwilling to
abandon the candidates that they
otherwise like so in other words
centrists are pro Democrat Force but the
other thing that's even that I think is
more actionable is that these voters
tend to be fairly politically informed
and democratically competent they seem
to be very fairly good at telling apart
undemocratic from democratic but also
knowing basic political facts and I
think so I think if there's hope it's
the Hope in this kind of voter as
serving as a check right so it's not
causal exactly it's an association but
it's it makes sense it's an association
and it's one only of about four or five
robust predictors across about 10
countries and so I think that that's the
kind of surprising thing is like
regardless of whether we talking about
Serbia Sweden or the United States this
is something that strongly correlates
with the kind of voter who's willing to
say if it's my side that's behaving
undemocratically I'm willing to switch
and vote for someone else precisely
because they're behaving
undemocratically Milan is this work um
part of the apsr paper that you
published with Matt or it's some other
this is this is not this is not
published uh this is not published all
right this is breaking news but it's B
it's based on those studies basically
looking now at the correlates of the
kind of voter that sides with democracy
okay but for people who are interested
in reading more about the what you've
been talking about the study that you
showed um excerpts from that's an
American Political Science review paper
with Matt Graham from
2022 there there is a paper there
although this one which is uh which I
showed is is also a working paper this
is this one is uh yeah this one is more
focusing on partisan mistrust great
thank you Jacob is is there some is
something you'd like to add yeah just I
just like to say first um bright line
watch is a great organization I'm so
pleased that um that that it's um that
it's out there and um I at least think
it has a presence at Yale because
there's a lot of us to admire and draw
on it um and I think that um if if I
could bring these comments together I'd
say two things one is yes voters are
kind of the ultimate corrective in
democratic system but the voters need
help right both they need institutions
that um that allow them to have an
effective voice and they need that kind
of information and support to be able to
exercise that and um and so there I come
back to this idea that there's just been
a there's a real need for building up
organizations broad kind of Civic
organizations of the of the sort that
you know used I think labor unions
played a very important role in this
regard as
um said and um but we also have uh as
Thea Scotch Bull's work has suggested
right we had a large number of kind of
mass-based Civic organizations some of
them fraternal organizations some of
them veterans groups that were much more
active uh in sort of mobilizing citizens
uh and informing them around broad
issues and um I would say that I am
short-term very worried as I've made
clear but I have a kind of long-term
optimism and it's it it rests on the on
a couple things one is that um you know
as we've discussed there's there's a
bunch of ideas out there for reform
right it's really what's the challenge
right now it's like the polit if you
can't it's like lifting yourself up by
your own bootstraps right the political
system isn't working very well how do we
fix the political system in those
circumstances but we kind of know the
formula you know and I I'm really
pleased that you Allan have created
democracy Innovations which is thinking
through some of these really innovative
ideas for how to improve the performance
of democracy I think how do we get
through this period where we can't
actually pursue those ideas we can
experiment we can think about state
level changes but I also think as as
Milan was suggesting right um we can we
can get engaged and um if there's one
thing that I think bright line watch
does that organizations do that Milan's
um uh Stronger Democrats in the
electorate do right is they try to to
focus attention on what the stakes are
right that's a little bit of what we're
doing but we uh at least I don't have
Illusions about how many people are
listening um uh well I can see right now
108 of you out there thank you for
listening so and hopefully you have lots
of friends you can talk to but I think
um one of the things that's happened is
we've kind of normalized pretty
fundamentally anti-democratic stances
and we need to to essentially say that
these are not uh these are not
appropriate and and that um and that's
got to be part of our our debates I
actually think it strik
that in the last um two big elections
actually probably if you go back to 2018
too right there's been a lot of hand
ringing and in the end where there's
been salience of the state about the
stakes right where there's candidates
who are really out there denying
elections where um you know very
fundamental rights that people care
about are at stake we've generally not
exclusively we've seen uh we've seen
great engagement right and we've seen a
lot of um positive breakthroughs to for
shoring up those institutions right and
so I think that's that's the Hope right
is that you get that going that kind of
positive cycle rather than the virtu the
Vicious Cycle going and I and I believe
over the long term we can excellent
thank you so much Jacob and so um I see
that we're at 523 I I do want to um say
thank you for the call out Jacob to uh
to the isps Democratic innovation
program we have a lot of events that are
planned in the coming um several months
including uh a fairly large um uh event
a conference event on rank Choice voting
um and we're having an event on the use
of lotteries and representational
systems and all sorts of things designed
to try and um and and think of systems
that would promote
honest uh efficient and Effective
Government um and I I I urge everyone
who's interested in such things to check
out the isps website for more
information so with that why don't we um
see if there are there any final uh like
literally 30 or 30 to 45 second comments
that that you'd like uh panelists to
make and if there's any uh resources or
papers or books that you think would be
especially important for people to read
who are interested in this subject could
you share those as well um we're we're
kind of getting close to the end of our
time together
together so why don't we start um in
reverse order from the presentation so
Milan uh Sue and then Jacob
please maybe very briefly I would say
that when I want to keep up
with um what political scientists and uh
what the public think about the state of
the US democracy I keep up with the
website of the bright line watch and
especially their reports on I'm I'm I'm
really fascinated by both how much
actually agreement there is between
political scientists and ordinary voters
about many things but also then the
lines of of disagreement so so I I find
those uh periodic studies incredibly
valuable and and kind of especially if
they're around major events um in
American politics like it's a it's I see
it as a social
scientific way to to better understand
um the challenges to democracy so I I I
really appreciate that thank you sue
uh thank you thanks thanks Milan um one
thing I would uh add is that we actually
um we actually have replicated the same
set of uh questions about dimensions of
democracy what you know what's important
um in I don't know six or seven
different countries very very varied
Brazil Poland the UK um South Africa um
bunch of different countries and it's
it's startling how similar the results
are so the the the view you know what's
what really matters for democracy what
what do you really what's essential you
know people think that equality of
rights of political rights they think
that election you know free and fair
elections Far and Away the most
important thing and also what doesn't
matter so much so they actually the V
POI is that um getting along and being
nice to each other it isn't isn't so
important I think you know like having
legislators who you know go out to
dinner together whatever they not that
they don't think it's important it's not
as important important so there's a
there's a lot of convergence of the
ideas about what democracy is um uh
internationally um I guess I would just
say um for for folks who are interested
in thinking about what you can do um and
and less of our our kind of uh Nery uh
papers that we write um another Yale
Professor Tim Snyder in the history
Department his um his book on his sort
of really basically pamphlet on tyranny
is a is a wonderful has a wonderful set
of ideas about very concrete things you
can do like get subscriptions to
newspapers and choose an organization
that you want to Champion and help labor
unions and so on so um I would I would
take a look at Tim's book great thanks a
lot Sue um and then Jacob please yeah so
first if you didn't notice CZ Sue was
talking I was holding up on tyranny
which is right next to my desk um but I
was also going to mention I'm part of
the American Academy of Arts and
Sciences Commission on reimagining the
economy and it's a successor to the this
is an embargoed copy and the real thing
doesn't have the the binder um but uh
it's a successor to a well-known report
that they did on improving America's the
health of American democracy and I think
it's really it's telling that first of
all you can get together a very broad
cross-section of people from very wide
range of fields and they all agreed that
it's really that our future of our
democracy depends on thinking about how
making we can make our economy work
better for more Americans and that
brings us full circle to where both Sue
and I began that you know ultimately
like capitalist democracy is is has this
you know among Rich democracies has this
pretty impressive track record of
resilience in the face of a lot of very
um fundamental shocks and it's rests on
this idea as Milan said that voters have
autonomy it also rests on the prosperity
that well well-regulated markets can
produce and um it's that you know that
compliment ity as as political
scientists called it of capitalism
democracy that um that with reforms to
both capitalism and democracy should get
us forward into the future um and and so
that I think it's really great that and
yes I know I think it's really great the
academy has put out a report for how we
might think about that fantastic thank
you so much Jacob so I I want to also
thank our staff at isps we have the most
amazing staff that allow us to do these
events especially Pam green Rick
Harrison and Kira wishart um who did all
of the arrangements to make this event
possible I want to thank our panelists
um uh Sue Stokes from Chicago Milan and
Jacob from Yale um and I also want to
thank everyone who attended our talk
today uh for the wonderful questions
they shared and the interesting
conversations those questions generated
um so with that thank you very much and
I forward to sharing additional isps
events in the future with all of you um
have a nice
evening thank
you